welcome back to new rock stars this
is a question the show that gives you
too much information about who in the
MCU is the most cold-blooded
cold-hearted bloodthirsty killer out
there my name is Tommy B boy bechtold
and I'm here today with Brandon don't
lock me up in the barracks that's right
keep me out of the barracks good to see
you Thomas glad to be doing a big
question with you oh you know me all my
questions are big when they come out of
this mouth
all right what's our big question for
today well Tommy phase four of the MCU
has come to an end and now that it's all
over we can finally look back at all the
movies in the series and special
presentations that were released in
phase four and start mining that sweet
sweet data and there's one stat Tommy
that interests me the most and It All
Leads us to this week's big question who
had the biggest kill count in phase four
of the MCU I love that question no it's
not biggest body count because that is a
titillating question but the kids they
refer to body count as something
different these days and I think we all
know the biggest body counts gotta go to
uh what's his name I can't cork cork has
the biggest body count I mean he he had
a good year yeah he had a good year he
got he found his partner anyway anyhow
okay so here's before we get to this I
want to mention this is how we got to
these numbers yeah we rewatched some
footage that's right we broke it down
like John Madden at the telestrator we
were circling bodies falling in frame by
frame frame by frame we also big fans of
the Marvel Wiki kill count page powered
by fandom that was very helpful we
watched some separate Clips we where we
did some documents we used right we
compiled we what we did is we aggregated
these kills aggravated aggregation is
what I call it so we're gonna start with
black widow this one's a little tough to
get a firm number on because we are
trying to only count the kills that
either happen on screen or are mentioned
on screen right also technically we can
build the film's main villain Drake off
responsible for any murders committed by
the wheels yeah because they're
programmed by him yeah you know but
again that's like it's not as direct
hands he's like telling them to kill
people and they've been killing people
for for decades exactly about how many
do we really attribute to Harry so in
that case we can count Elena's killing
of Oxana plus Ingrid whacking herself
off no hang on let me take that again
plus Ingrid kill yourself under Drake
mom's orders and Natasha's mom who was
killed off screen by Drake off getting
that guy a total number of three years
you're saying that's Drake off via Widow
getting some kills he didn't really kill
anyone by himself like a true coward and
a True Villain all of his kills were
orchestrated by
um by ordering other people around now
whatever the real MVP of this movie
though is Elena who just couldn't stop
killing she's a killer 614 kills what
including 595 Russian prisoners and
guards killed by the Avalanche caused
verified by a scroll a line in a scroll
not a scroll a scroll oh like a news
thing at the bottom remember in the MCU
anytime there's a television and there's
the news you gotta you gotta check the
bottom right there so so 614 total
because she kills like almost 600 people
just in that prison oh my gosh oh my
gosh some of those people are innocent I
don't trust the Russian some of those
Russian guards were just like honey this
is my last day and then I'm gonna go be
that Elementary I mean this is like the
Stormtroopers on the Death Star right
like some of them are just accountants
some of them are just running the mess
hall you don't want to you don't want to
think too hard about it guys so you
won't be able to sleep at night okay
that's that's a big one to start with
okay uh our next our next film that was
released uh was shanxi and the legend of
the ten Rings okay now now we had we had
a few deaths a lot of these were
mentioned off screen but we'll go
through it shangshi's mother Ying Li is
killed by the iron gang uh so give one
to the iron gang folks uh we see a lot
of people have their souls sucked out by
the Soul Eaters uh including the death
dealer themselves yeah you know just
when we think they're gonna get reaction
boom Salt's gone a lot of soul sucking
in MCU Facebook I gotta say I knew a
soul sucker back in college and I hope
she's doing well all right
anyway so so uh you know the little Soul
suckers they're getting some some kill
counts up but our hero of the film
shangshi himself okay he's killing
people in this movie all right he racks
up a few kills of his own over the
course of the film he kills the leader
of the iron gang though this is off
screen but he mentions it uh he also
throws several Tang ring members out of
the bus and into traffic during the bus
fight I mean they gotta be dead yeah
there's no he there's no way he's doing
the math and he's like oh if I bounce
this dude off a truck he'll he'll hit
some some garbage bags on those San
Francisco streets and live no he's
killing people if you're on a bus in a
Marvel movie you're halfway expecting to
die yeah lost insurance policies must be
through the roof dude that that is a
side thing yeah uh public transportation
is a death trap in the MCU feige had a
bad experience at a bus when he was a
kid got bullied on the bus and now buses
are his main target between buses and
like Metro trains above ground
underground it is dangerous to be on
Public Training you know who I suspect
big Uber the Uber
big Uber is paying to have all these
public transportation things destroyed
taxes constantly getting leveled
constantly when do you ever see an Uber
sticker getting swapped that's right
that's the same thing that's the safest
thing out there
um she also kills his father Wen Wu uh
though you could argue one who kind of
lays down yeah it's like trying to cheat
you got to kill me to get the rings and
I think and I think he saw the error of
his way yeah it was more of a sack it
was an atonement but you know shanxi
still does it and then of course
shangshi kills the dweller in darkness
yeah that's a big kill that's a huge and
if as we're going through this if you
want to weight that a little heavier
than just one kill like should that be
weighted heavier that's a big beast yeah
is like a hundred I don't know I don't
know how many hearts does it have
because if it's like a worm and it has
seven hearts and then kind of this seven
I just count this as heartbeats stopping
oh okay okay that's good uh plus Zhang
XI and his sister XI Ling they killed
quite a few 10 Rings members throughout
the movie by dropping them off buildings
or kicking them into Bottomless Pits or
stabbing them with roaches there sure
she's killing a lot of people
um but let's look at when we're himself
okay he has killed thousands of people
over the years oh maybe more tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people he's been alive for a long time
uh but we do on screen see him wipe out
quite a few people throughout history
and in the present day right uh early in
the movie you see him just wiping out
hordes of like uh uh Knights and uh
other Warriors and stuff like that so
we've got to give when we're the highest
kill count of this film with at least
100 people killed on screen he he did
the most killing on screen absolutely we
cannot ignore uh shangshi's bloodlust no
I mean like father like son an eternal
Bond speaking of Eternal bonds I bonded
with this eternals movie because you
know what they showed on-screen level
thinking about about time you know me
I'm a lover first about time now I gotta
I gotta sign big questions for you Tommy
I was thinking about this when we were
doing some research I was thinking about
the scene again do are the robots are
the Eternal robots do they have do they
have like reproductive juices they got
the organs but is are there eggs inside
of Cersei is there sperm inside Icarus
I'm gonna say yes based on the vision
rules because like Vision has it right
oh that's true because he's able to make
cakes right but he's also half organic
we don't know how organic I like to
think they're organic and orgasmic I
mean you know I would hope that erisham
or whoever built these eternals at least
gave them the I hope he gave them too
much and it's just like porno cream of
mushroom soup Style
oh
goodbye
the film covers a long span of time but
we'll try to narrow it down to on-screen
deaths that we see the eternals wipe out
some deviants here and there sure do we
consider them sentient enough to uh
beings to be part of the kill count I
think so you think so they're kind of
like animals I don't know except for
yeah I didn't count animals so you're
right Pro seems to be the most I mean
they give them kind of a human he he's
bipedal yeah we have Crow killing
Gilgamesh and Ajax with an assist by
Icarus for the Ajax yeah he throws them
down he wounds her yeah but also we see
him kill a worker on an oil platform
Icarus flies himself into the sun after
being a real [ __ ] although we are
debating whether or not Icarus I think
he's alive I think he flew right through
it and he's like well that didn't work
ah damn I really am unkillable uh Athena
kills Crow by slicing him up and then
Cersei kills Tiamat uh should she get a
bonus point for that
big that's a big death but it is a baby
that's the top yeah not a good look for
Cersei all right let's chat about the
teammate of it all real quick yeah yes
it happened in an uninhabited island in
the Indian Ocean but surely the
emergence caused some tsunamis that
would have wiped out some Villages or
nearby Shores all that displaced water
has to go somewhere yeah yeah I mean
there should be some implied deaths I
mean they've rarely talked about Tiamat
and everything that's come after the
Eternal aside from a little note on
She-Hulk where they mention it but like
there must have been some people killed
on the shoreline there's probably like a
boat in the water that guy yeah yeah
that's right some crab fisherman
foreign
anyway Also let's not forget brand new
spools of standing water inland from all
of this that water gets infectious real
fast
old grandmother sipping and contaminated
water this might be good for a stew
three months later she's dead as a door
now
all right
every Celestial we've seen was born out
of a planet so each of the four we see
mean there were at least eight million
185 million 614 000 sentient beings
wiped out for each little celestial
[Music]
but again we didn't see that happen so
it's hard to like justify that I don't
know we're not gonna count those we're
not going to count it we should also
note that the eternals just let a lot of
people die due to their inaction do
those count as kills do we lay any blame
on fastos facetos fastos Fosters do we
lay any blame on fostos for the atom
bombs dropped in World War II he blames
himself he does blame himself but again
he's just like he didn't fly the adult
right and he didn't hypnotize the pilots
to do it I think the Mind Control to me
is where you give them credit right yeah
Druid wanted to use his mind control to
stop people from killing people right he
was trying to do good so I mean you can
lay a lot of this blame at the eternal's
feet again they were robots they're full
of too much sperm they didn't know what
they were doing they were sperm-filled
robots that's why their eyeballs they
didn't know what they were just
following orders they're like we're not
supposed to interfere we got to let the
heat there what happens when they blow
their nose
that ain't snot
they were told to like let the humans do
their thing let them kill each other but
help them get smarter they didn't know
what they were doing but like again I
don't know this this is a hard kill
count to like figure yeah Turtles is a
tough one to figure out as a movie and
as a big question so like very low
on-screen deaths maybe Crow kills the
most on screen You Gotta Give Crow the
most I also yeah I mean I kind of feel
like yeah I think the Tiamat is the big
kill yeah but I think Crow has the most
kills but that kind of makes sense
eternals was not a like particularly
bloody violence it's a lot of implied
violence yeah it's a lot about the the
choices it's about the consequence of
choice yeah all right all right let's
talk about Spider-Man no way home okay
our good friend Green Goblin to use some
unusual restraint in this movie only
killing like nine people right eight
police officers with his pumpkin bombs
and of course
our dear friend Aunt May oh God Marissa
Tomei counts as a 2000. I I mean like
you know she got killed by wounds from
his glider but that should be like 2 000
deaths I mean that is a uh if you're
gonna weight these deaths if we're gonna
give them a little extra sauce like
that's a heavy death also two gliding
men committed mother figures in MC air
committed murder on mother figure Neymar
was like this all right I'm good I'm
sure I'm Gonna Make You you want to I'm
Gonna Make You the queen of wakanda now
and then Green Goblin was like Peter I'm
gonna show you why you're like
compassion and Reliance on family makes
you weak yeah like why is wrong who hurt
these people who hurt these people are
men okay
no they're not uh men would rather throw
gliders into people's ants than go to
therapy I make that joke it's every
video it's never that funny we edit it
out of every other video but we'll leave
it in this one oh Tommy down Tommy down
we also got to mention Doc Ock uh and no
way home he got in the kill game as well
by killing according to the uh the wiki
fandom that we checked out uh he killed
12 Unknown People when he blew up the
bridge near the beginning of the movie
yeah some of those people have gotta
have died yeah before he broke back good
yeah before he He Turned good yeah Green
Goblin has the most kills in this and
that makes sense I mean even though
dakak has like more Einstein kills I
think you gotta give it to Green Goblin
yeah I may going down and I think Green
Goblin purposely
vaporized those cops with his pumpkin
bombs whereas Doc Ock was probably just
trying to get yeah his murder his deaths
even two are like collateral damage to
get to Spiderman who he's just trying to
kill Spiderman for everything killing
his wife yeah let's talk about speaking
of wives let's talk about moms
multiverses of Madness of course Wanda
maximoff really went hey I'm racking up
a pretty good kill count back to stream
Multiverse Madness she wiped out
Defender strange via one of her monsters
they used her actual eye to create the
eye in the visual effects so I'm
counting that yeah plus she wiped out
five of the 838 Illuminati members by
dream walking into another Wanda plus 18
Ultron sentries which you know those are
basically synthesis yeah they're robots
I don't know if that counts all right
knock them out if I smash my uh Amazon
Alexa with a hammer am I a murderer I
got you myrrh thank you murder
what you say why Brandon please because
you walked out asking me to did you ask
you what if I played Billy Joel no I
didn't say that Alexa stop
Alexa stop
confirmed
and in the 616 she's responsible for
killing 89 masters of the Mystic Arts at
Commerce how many Masters of the Mystic
Arts do they have I mean she had to have
knocked out about 50 of the workflow I I
think like the next day or a week later
or whatever uh a bunch of people had
submitted application suddenly got like
yeah oh you get to come to Commerce and
then they get there like why did I get
why are there so many new ones
why does it smell like waffles around
here the crematorium's been pretty
active we won't count Sarah wolf as she
stabs the dark hold and dies out I don't
think you can blame one sacrifices I'm
not giving that one to Wanda all right
both Supreme strains from a38 and
Sinister strange have killed trillions
thanks for the incursions but those are
all off screen and we don't really get
implied deaths yeah implied deaths but
yeah we didn't see we didn't see those
people scream out in Terror as their
worlds were collided into other worlds
agreed so Sinister or Doctor Strange
himself kills gargantos and Sinister
strange plus three of the Knights of
Wonder Gore that he throws off the
mountains eats them right out not bad in
the end though Wanda takes this film
with at least 94 on-screen kills go
Wanda go on from matanda to awanda you
go girl you go girl yes Queen Slay
Slay your enemies okay Thor 11 Thunder
baby our big bad Gore the god butcher
I've said a few gods in the films and
even if we don't see all the deaths we
do see a lot of the bodies okay
he kills rappu which we see of course
then we also see the bodies of like the
Sequoia king and queen I love the
Sequoia King I want him back well too
bad All Gods Must Die uh we also see the
body of Fallon guard and four other
phala Guardians and octi yeah uh so we
see those bodies but really the big
killer in this film is again our heroes
yes Thor Jane and Valkyrie I mean
they're wiping out aliens shadow monster
Zeus's guards all over the place I mean
Thor tries to kill Zeus can't kill them
he's pretty unkillable but in the end I
think Jane Foster winds up killing the
most in this film it's really hard to
tell because a lot of them are like
deaths around other people like they get
attributed to like either Thor Jane or
Valkyrie or one of the other but I think
Jane Foster Ryan winds up with at least
like 136 deaths in this movie and then
Cancer's the big killer no boy Jane
Foster you a bad beer she bad girl black
panther wakanda forever baby this film
was heavy on the off-screen death to
doubt heavily in the concept of grief we
don't see that many on-screen hopefully
now the teleconil killed Jackson and
Rita deep in the ocean atuma kills a few
people on the boat looking for vibranium
right the Falcon it'll make about 20
people jump into the water from the
research boat another 27 jump into the
water when they invade wakanda although
I'm unclear as to whether or not out in
the ocean probably everyone who jumped
off that boat down because there's no
way to get back
but like I think because then they throw
the grenade in yeah I think they wake up
and they're like oh yeah they're just
like they're gonna swim I'd love to see
a a Marvel one shot right swimming to
shore uh it's also hard to tell if
anyone dies during the flooding avocado
but I think we could safely say come on
50 what continents yeah that seems like
I think that's a good estimate right
like it's not the whole it's not the
whole Golden City it's a few of the
streets I I was checking like there's no
there's the news report of raimonda's
death but there's no ticker like you
know 100 people dying what kind of right
they don't even know what happened right
they just say it's some civil contract
or something like that I have a feeling
I think at least 50 people had to have
died in like the water rushing through
the city I agree and I mean especially
like we don't know what damage happened
to the outside like farmlands too right
like if any water trickled down there
again the standing water is
three months later she's dead as a door
now without a boil water notice what
continent government officials Jesus I
could see in a upcoming MCU property
than being like no more killed a
thousand left yeah and then we're all
gonna have to go back and be like all
right but we didn't know we'll have to
do a big question Revisited now we also
see nemour killed Dr Graham and the
pilot when you kill Lake Bell you go to
hell okay you do not kill a treasure
like Lake Bell and of course he kills
Queen ramonda again another happy death
there probably should be waited
differently so you made a good argument
that she kind of sacrifices herself yeah
he gives her the option right because if
she doesn't save Riri right she uh she
she doesn't say reread she lives right
she's trying to kill Riri he's not
necessarily trying to kill her right so
she made the choice save to save the
child save the world save the
Cheerleader Save the World and then he
did remember Heroes folks uh and then he
did you know he wanted him he's like
don't mess with us and we're kind of
kind of struck first yeah again Sherry
was kidnapped right but uh you know it's
difficult it's difficult we also don't
know how many people like no more is
killed over time right but he's
definitely killed a lot yeah he killed
those priests that were attacking his uh
Village when he's trying his uh or his
mother's Village right when he was
trying to bury her now Nikia does shoot
a couple of tele Canal each of them
seemed to be able to regenerate but at
least two of them yeah I don't know the
regenerative rules for the telecono
because we do see like a lot of bodies
on the board
stand back up but some of them stay down
and I like to think that like the
wakandan surgeons used all the beads
like they had their own little groupies
yeah and they just started like
everybody just got up and walked away
after that some people a little
zombified you know they lost a lot of
oxygen to the brain they were never
quite the same again now during the
final battle on the boat there are
fallen wakandans and telekinesis like we
said it's hard to tell who killed who
it's not very close the Tuma does not
appear to be dead we're gonna try and
get him on the on a new Rockstar show to
answer that for us we have the same
manager so I'm going to get hold of it
too much so I think the more I think the
more probably had the highest yeah
because you've got to assume what
continents died in the attack and he's
he's also given the orders right if
we're going by Drake rules like he's
ordering the the sirens to draw people
into the ocean so and as a villain he is
a unique one because like uh embaku says
he's not their King no he's not their
General he is literally their God yeah
so they they believe they are acting on
his orders with whatever they do you
know like that's why I think uh nemoura
is so hurt at the end and she's like
wait a second my entire belief system
makes me think you would not do this
yeah and then you do so let's give them
the more between the like the 50 people
and the flooding yeah the priests in the
past yeah uh a few other people here and
there we'll give him like 100 kills
kills I think that's fine and thousands
of Thrills Thanks for the Memories no
more okay that's all the movies in
Facebook yeah we did it folks now let's
get into the television we did not do
what if because it's a cartoon it's a
little different yeah I know some of the
stuff that happens in there appears to
be Canon right we uh we didn't include
what if so go ahead and call in if that
upsets you yeah uh our phone number is
9-1-1 and just tell them that you are a
[ __ ] when you call okay first things
first kick us off with the television
series
we still have some deaths baby that's
right lots of ambiguity as to who the
villain on this show is some would say
Wanda but I think Agatha is definitely
one of the baddies and she killed seven
witches including her own mother I'm
sorry in addition to her own they were
trying to kill her in a flashback yeah
but she killed him or take at least take
her powers she also killed Sparky the
dog which is just plain unfortunately I
know we weren't counting animals but
dogs are people right I mean dogs are
basically I mean I know people that
treat their animals like their children
so as long as you know that exists in
this world we're gonna give we're gonna
give Agatha Nine Kills Wanda herself
takes out Billy Tommy and viz
that's a heavy
do we consider those like real kills I
mean it's real to her it's real to her I
mean she great she Mourns the losses and
that's really it for the difference on
the show I still say though Agatha is
the leader in the kill house yeah you
don't think you don't think maybe
there's also a couple people in the
neighborhood you know how Wanda was like
barely controlling the people on like
yeah it's like she forgot to have one
like go to the bathroom and they die
from an exploded bladder or something
like that there's a few maybe she
doesn't know someone has a peanut
allergy and she's like yeah
Wanda up to eight putting her just
barely below I'm gonna say there were
five accidental deaths that arwanda's
fault one guy uh he likes to Tinker with
ham radio so she forgot to like have him
ground the area around it himself yeah I
I want that
I know when they're Soldier folks Sharon
Carter had was the party starter she had
13 kills as she was revealed to be the
power broker yes uh she shot backdrop
the leaper in the head R.I.P my guy the
leaper someone reconstruct his body and
he seems revivable right he's the best
he's the best film we got in the MCU uh
she also uh
she also shot Carly the flag Smasher in
the chest uh she melted Linux with
acidic Vapor it's just what took out two
people at the club and eight people in
the shipping yard so she's uh she's a
stone cold killer this second one
floored me Our Heroes Our Heroes folks
Sam Wilson also tallied 10 kills after
dropping some laf agents out of a
helicopter before exploding in yeah
first he had the decency to drop like
five of them and then he exploded I mean
I guess
they were breaking the law sure did not
get a court uh is is is is is Sam Wilson
is Judge Judy Captain America he's just
a killer uh Bucky came in with 12 kills
through many though many of those kills
came in flashback scenes while he was
under Hydra controls I don't know would
you count there still mad at him for
killing Mr nakajima's son though yeah
it's dirty he you know I mean he paid
his Penance I guess Zemo had six kills
mostly in the shipping yard scene and of
course taking out the three to ten
fights Masters by ordering ozmik to blow
up their transport uh Carly had five
kills most memorably breaking Battle
Stars neck by tossing him into a pillar
yes
rip Battlestar we hardly knew you
finally our good old U.S agent John
Walker kill Nico by Smashing him
repeatedly with cap Shield I mean to me
that was the most that was it that was
the most brutal death yeah up until
werewolf by night I think yeah yeah well
you know if you consider things like uh
you know Frank and Ant-Man game like
disintegrated
Wanda and Kombat was burning people
alive yeah she was doing and putting
making her killed himself yeah yeah
doing some brutal stuff there but yeah
brutally smashing a dude's face in with
cap shield with the blood splattering
that that was pretty heavy you're right
that was pretty good all right let's get
Loco for Loki okay Sylvie had the most
skills with 19 including several minutes
yeah Hunter U 92 and of course he who
remains Big Time kill totally changing
the hierarchy of power in the MC that's
right forever yeah why don't you accept
the challenge there tough guy lucky you
only had two kills one train guard he
chucked off a train another one stabbed
in the chest efficient efficient maybe
the most brutal death came off screen
but was said on screen by Kid Loki who
revealed that he killed Thor oh yeah
he went the good son on his brother dude
yeah why are you here I killed Thor cool
man well anyway I'm gonna talk to some
of the other Loki's because you seem
like a real psychopath it's simple we
kill the thought all right let's talk
about hot guy it's no surprise that the
deadliest person in Hawkeye is well
Hawkeye yeah yeah he had 24 kills in the
series mostly track two mafia members
and of course he stabbed William Lopez
in a flashback scene as the Ronin oh yes
but when we talk about brutal deaths in
the MCU I don't think there is anything
more brutal than shrinking down those
three tracksuit Mafia yeah guys in the
truck and letting an owl carry them away
yes go look up on the Internet how it
out eats its prey yeah can you imagine
drunk down bones and I'm watching you
and your tracksuit Brothers being ripped
apart by the beak of an owl yes
foreign
that is just insane that that was on a
TV show
that's a hawk okay Bishop also killed
three members of the tracksuit Mafia now
most of the time they're trying not to
kill they're using like they're
attacking now but they're also not like
well don't shoot that Arrow at them they
might accidentally yeah you can argue
that they're hitting like safe spots on
the body and just pinning them down but
some of these people are dying go back
and watch I think for reference those of
us that are fans watch the Pete Holm
sketch where he plays Batman and he's
just killing all of the people with his
batarangs he's like I don't kill yeah
yeah and then they're like you just
clearly killed that guy he's got a he's
got a batarang through his eyeball when
I when I'm playing this Spider-Man game
on my PlayStation 5 humble work got a
PlayStation 5. oh yeah Flex on them go
watch how you treat some of those gang
members they're not alive just because
you webbed a guy 50 stories up off the
ground he's a dead man yeah he's not
coming back how do you think when that
web's this is great do you think he
lands on a web yeah you think someone's
getting to him in time you're going
around the city putting webs webbed up
bad guys over the city they're not all
getting sick congrats You're a murderer
yeah yeah uh Kingpin also gets credit
for three kills do by his own hand and
one by ordering Eleanor Bishop to kill
Armand Duquesne III uh shockingly our
big killer Elena only has one killer
well that brings her total up to 6 15
though I believe she's she's set a good
face for her well the night time is the
right night or the right time the night
time is the right time for killing
that's right the giant amick has 91
kills so 80 of them were through
absorbing the life forces but people
being judged by Ahmed the others were
mostly surrogate kills by Arthur Harrell
speaking of Arthur Harrow had 17 kills
himself he was absorbing souls and
digging holes in the name of Ahmed but
he also had a great time killing all
those avatars in the pyramid that's
right that's right boom uh he he took
down the nice guy in the fancy suit he
took down the ladies
lady in the pantsuit did all of them
yeah Moon Knight himself
kind of unfair had 74 kills that
includes uh killing firm of Specter
Grant and lockley the majority of those
were kills were Disciples of Amit but he
also killed Amit themselves himself
herself tough to tell Gator it's not the
fell on alligators gender uh let's cut
off well they well it is tough to tell
they have cloacas yeah which you may
know as a reptile so you have to stick
your finger inside the cloak in order to
sex an alligator oh well if that's all I
have to sex an alligator maybe I'll just
stick to sexing nothing at all uh also
Jake lockley appeared to shoot Arthur
harrow in the final scene of the show so
that's where his cat maybe alive maybe
did I don't know can't you F Murray
Abraham killed that voice acting role in
one and Emmy for it uh he also accounted
for 26 kills on the show and probably 26
million additional kills throughout all
the time play like a Scarlet Scarab got
in on the kill Game knocking off five
Disciples of amid inside the pyramid
beautiful yes beautiful of course we had
Miss Marvel not much death in this show
only the murder of Aisha by najma which
we saw in the train station flashback
who uh we needed a break
that was a a show geared to a younger
audience though they do mention cocaine
yeah not as much death on that show you
know what cocaine is approved a lot of
Saturday mornings for people I think
finally Seahawk attorney at law folks
according to the Marvel Wiki again
powered by fandom thank you very much
the only thing killed by the She-Hulk
series was the v-neck t-shirt murdered
by toddler
also we can we can pretty much agree
that uh uh Jennifer's bed was destroyed
when She-Hulk went to town yeah I would
say the box I would say that like like a
college kid that mattress and boxing
were on the floor by the end what bed
frame could hold She-Hulk and Daredevil
she's gonna have to order a new Helix
Matrix yeah that's for sure you know
what the Helix mattress has mattress
sizes for all people they're not a
sponsor but I am a fan including Hawks
send me that big boy mattress Helix and
make bed frames I'm tired of sleeping on
the floor all right uh we can't neglect
the special presentations Tommy yes we
are well off by night they talk about
their previous monster kills uh when
they're first yeah but that should not
count again off screen we see some like
kills and pictures and statues but again
that shouldn't count I want to stop
right here real quick because we keep
saying off screen doesn't when the
person describes killing a character in
the show right right we count that yeah
when they're like over the last hundred
years I've killed 15 monsters we don't
count that so when all you're making
your cute little comments in the comment
board that I don't read but I do read
them when I'm drunk it doesn't count I'm
two different people I'm Jake lockley
when I have tequila when The Rock makes
me drink tequila I become Jake lockley
I don't care okay I don't care if you
don't think the method is sound We Are
Scientists we are we are death
scientists yes anyway back to you Brando
yeah okay so and werewolf By Night Elsa
kills liorn with the little crossbow
adorable uh and barasso and Azrael with
a sword uh she just a lot of killing in
this nice work uh Ted are are a good man
thing he kills Joshua and barusa
Bloodstone with his melty melting hands
yeah and Jack winds up killing five
guards so yeah in this little horror
presentation we got some deaths and they
were they were awesome they were awesome
and uh last but not least the Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special
Christmas spirits
conclusion all right so Tommy who was
our biggest killer in phase four well if
we're going by our parameters that we
laid out throughout this video I think
we gotta go with my love of my life
Florence
with 614 kills in black widow and one
additional kill in Hawkeye bring you to
a cool
615 on-screen or on-screen
Elena you did it look in your mail
you'll be getting a suspicious package
from us okay can it be a life a first
aid kit she was converted from Black
Widow to Hero but she's mostly been a
hero with yeah yeah and she's leading
the death and she did a lot of these
kills as a hero right right right right
right
you either die a hero or live long
enough to kill as a hero uh I think and
I think we got to give an honorable
mention to the Green Goblin if you're
taking out anime yeah just yeah
devastating stuff so so many Great Kills
guys really great great series great
phase of kills I hope the killing face
carries on to phase five speaking of
carrying on to phase five be sure to
check out new rockstarsmerch.com you can
grab some sweet new rockstars merch for
the holidays I myself have been sending
hoodies to strangers this is something I
do to scare them and if you want to get
some gifts for the nerds in your life
but you don't know the shirt sizes you
know you want to buy you've been dating
zone for three weeks they're a nerd you
don't want to order them to size up and
be like oh did you think I was a medium
I'm a smile guess what we have size
agnostic merch options like hat stickers
mugs and enamel pins how
send me a DM on Instagram and I'll wish
you a happy birthday support the channel
check out all of our awesome merch
options all over the new
rockstarsmerch.com that's right check it
out uh we also got to thank Verity for
sponsoring the video today Tommy I don't
know about you yeah I do not consider
myself a stylish guy
in style magazine said oh
not again his nipples are poking out of
that t-shirt hey some people pay a lot
of money for that uh I don't like
shopping for clothes I hate it it's
annoying fashion confuses me I don't
understand it there's no point it hurts
my brain half the time they're in Saran
wrap on the catwalk what are we even
supposed to do with that that's why I
like when I can find a brand that does
The Styling for me yes and that's why I
like fairies I love you in a fairy I've
got their classic shirt though oh yeah
the legend sweater too I love that thing
it's so good but their website's great
because I know you can just put the
pieces together and you can make a good
outfit and you look cool okay fairy is a
family brand that channels their
Founders love of the beach Lifestyle the
clothing for lifestyle greatest moments
absolutely Verity is passionate about
craftsmanship comfort and sustainability
their ongoing partnership with Native
designer supports native communities
while helping end appropriation and
fashion every piece is designed to be a
lifetime favorite and if anything
happens along the way Verity will
replace or fix your clothes for life no
matter what you don't got to tell them
how those burn holes got there they'll
fix it for you layer up this winter with
the best-selling Legend sweater shirt
for men women and kids I love the shirt
it's great it's so comfy it looks
awesome it's great they also have
recycled High pile fleece jackets and
new Frost sweaters to check out like I
said Tommy I love their clothes it's
very easy to mix and match and look good
I also found out they have store
locations like physical locations is
there one in the South land there is one
on the south land I went to one in
Charleston everyone there was very
helpful thank you so much it was awesome
all over the country check out their
website to find out if there's a fairy
near you I'm gonna say this I hope we
have a promo code coming up because this
year 2023 coming off next year I'm gonna
kiss a girl for the first time and it's
going to be in a faraday shirt I
guarantee it guys we'll answer it on the
big questions we'll bring her on she'll
talk about the experience give them that
promo code Big Daddy well Tommy farity
is giving all big question fans an
amazing deal 20 off on your order head
to ferritybrand.com Big q and use code
big Q at checkout to get this deal
that's code big Q at Verity FAA
h-e-r-t-ybrand.com bigq for twenty
percent off veritybrand.com and remember
you can't spell Verity without why
father now it's true from the hive mind
it's time to respond to the masses you
focus submitted your questions via
Twitter Discord Instagram just general
screaming into the void I received an
owl of a suspicious letter very Harry
Potter of you we're here to answer them
does the trajectory of Cinema change
within the MCU with the inclusion of
Captain America and other Heroes that
affect history that was from Louis Joe
five eight two six five zero two three
on Twitter definitely not a bot no gotta
be a real person uh thank you Lewis Joe
uh I love this question because it's
something we like to think about online
uh the MCU has shown that popular films
television shows and other media that
exist in our universe also exist in
theirs right we've had references to
Star Wars aliens Superman and the DC
Universe in general yeah Back to the
Future heck we even saw a young Wanda
watching Dick Van Dyke yes happy
birthday Dick Van Dyke by the way 97
years old at the time of this filming
that's right uh and hopefully alive in
97. he lives in the 616 he exists there
too God bless you Dan but Dick Van Dyke
and all your variants yeah uh but in a
world that also has super powered
individuals meddling in world affairs
does that mean the media would reflect
that as well uh in Spider-Man far from
home we saw Peter flip through some of
this all alternate history Cinema on his
flight to Europe right with titles like
the snap finding wakanda and hunting
Hydra tracking the world's most
dangerous criminals and the show Agent
Carter even showed how Howard Stark
owned his own movie studio Stark
pictures Howard was even turning his
favorite comic book kid cult into a
movie wow
we've even seen that like the comic
books that we have in our world exist in
the 616 right we saw the Captain America
comic with him punching Hitler that
exists there and exists in ours uh there
was also a deleted scene from Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 that showed a fake movie
poster for a biopic on Tony Stark in the
style of the Danny Boyle film Steve Jobs
alive which is just like hilarious and
great yes uh but much like the way the
film and glorious bastard showed how an
alternate history around World War II
would change the way that Cinema existed
in that future we would have to assume
that in the MCU the legend of Captain
America running around the battlefield
would have been represented in the
annual Universe war movies that came out
within the MCU and I bet Howard Stark
produced some of them because he loved
his little Steve projects he loved those
TV so imagine like the bridge over the
River Kwai exists yeah but then like
Captain America runs through it at some
point yes 30 dozen is replaced by the
howling Commando yeah yeah yeah so
there's got to be a Howling Commandos
movie out there too right right so to
answer your question like yes all these
Heroes would affect things I bet uh in
the friends of the show Friends in the
MCU the Chandler makes a joke like could
you be any more Captain America yes yes
because Joey gets like a a pair of like
American flag shoebox now here's my
here's what I think uh oh I lost it oh
it was so good it was such a great oh
this was gonna be such a thing yeah oh
here's what it is okay yeah 55 year old
women have to buy like Captain America
World War II literature for their
husbands as Christmas gifts because
they've fallen out of love yeah they
have a sexless marriage anyway let's go
to box subscribe I'm glad we circled
back yeah glad we got to it all right
Tommy it's time for the box of scraps
and I gotta put it in the game with a
box of scrape Jordy Stark and it came
a bunch of scraps technology
uh since it's the season for gift giving
Tommy yeah for today's box of scraps
what is the one toy you wanted the very
real Santa Claus to bring you for
Christmas that you never received oh how
did Santa let you down oh well you know
first of all I have to credit Santa for
giving me some real highlights okay
Ghostbusters Firehouse oh that was a
good that's a big place I had the
Ghostbusters like kind of Nerf uh
ectopus
I actually still have the Pack oh I my
nephews play with it now uh well they're
little they probably be embarrassed by
that but they did they still did they're
still playing uh I also I have to give a
a shout out to uh my mom for getting me
the WWE then the WWF ring with Titantron
playset we have the figures where you
stepped on the Square and it's your
entrance music Place yeah that's good
shout out I'm sorry Santa so thank you
for that yeah yeah but
my white whale the one toy I never
received the one toy most of us never
received because it was so gratuitous
I wasn't allowed to have GI Joes oh too
much capaganda too much too much guns
not enough fun I can have Ninja Turtles
with swords of All Sorts but once the
humans had the guns that's where Mama
Bechtel said no mas the aircraft carrier
I forget what it's called you know the
aircraft carrier from GI Joe was the
coveted it came in a massive box okay
the box is like the size of this death
sure sure uh it was probably at that
point you know with inflation it was
probably like 125 was just like sure
would you like the cost of like a PS5
yeah insane uh my family was not wealthy
but they always my parents made it
Christmas it was always amazing for us
and I was sure sure that Santa would
forego my mother's warnings if GI Joe
and get me that battleship
did that son of a [ __ ] bring it for me
and years later they reso they sold a
remake at Comic-Con at the Hasbro booth
for an obscene amount of money and I
have to tell you it took every inch of
restraint I had to not buy it I didn't
buy it what about you Brandon well again
Big Ups of Santa for coming through a
lot of years got a NES system yeah when
it came out yeah that's great uh got a
pair of rollerblades even though I lived
on a dirt road in the middle of nowhere
that seems unsafe well that makes me
have to go to a roller rink in order to
use them that would make me more believe
in Santa which was of course real yeah
Santa is very well uh for the kids
watching but uh just because of the
irresponsibility of the gift your mom
would never buy you rollerblades what am
I gonna do but where Santa let me down
oh my gosh Lego uh made a monorail
system that like was motorized and it
moved on the monorail this was featured
in the film The Witches a horrifying
tale where a boy gets turned into a
mouse and doesn't get Unturned oh God it
gets to ride on the Lego monorail so I
guess that's a bonus I asked for that
Lego monorail system every year again
very expensive very pricey for parents
to buy or Santa to build uh and I never
got it and to this day I still don't
have it though I have many Lego sets I
have not purchased the monorail set
because it's my white whale and I just
want it to be free and I don't deserve
it it's Gotta come organically into your
life speaking of coming organically
the eternals uh
uh they've had a tough go of it that's
it for the big question uh today I want
to thank Brandon thank you Tommy oh what
a joy what a fun time we had we brought
it in in under an hour the editors are
still going to be upset with us because
I just can't help myself follow Brandon
at Green and Barrick you won't regret it
folks follow me at Tommy bechtold you'll
regret it immediately follow at new
rockstars here on YouTube and all other
social media platforms hit that
notification please do like like the
video for crying out loud and we will
see you later bye bye
goodbye
[Music]